yeah I'm excited we got a couple of news
guys uh Matt Padgett and Chris Pereira
that's right against Rob handlery Henry
and editor Scott butterworth that's true
that's who we are going to see right now
they're playing their burner match in
terms of a scouting report literally no
idea what's going on for the news guys
but they did send me some intel Chris
Pereira I freelancer and he's a wild
card in the match due to the fact that
his cat might interrupt in some fashion
shows whether the feline will be a
factor here for the orange team as
format Paget based out of Vancouver the
Canuck is hoping we're all going to
raise an o Canada anthem at the end of
this match in victory to celebrate it is
win feeling pretty confident even though
let's see what his rocket league
experience is like mostly plays singles
and clotheslines himself as a defensive
player okay so we got the bracket I can
pull up here quick show where we are at
this is the first round match it's match
number one there in the top left the
winner of this is going to go on to face
Andy Bauman and Justin who have a
first-round bye but now we are ready to
get started or so let's jump in where
this is a best-of-three match so it's
gonna be over pretty quick even if it
goes to the full three matches but uh
it's gonna be an exciting one Mike
because it's always fun to see new
competitors on the scene yeah we've had
a lot of relative relatively unknown
people coming into the tournament you
know we play a lot in the office but
we've got you know Rob who I think a lot
of us know how he plays we got Scott
who's pretty new to rocket League but
then like you were just saying Chris and
Matt both experienced but we don't know
too much about them so it should be
interesting absolutely ah all right and
here we have the kickoff both teams meet
in the middle and it's going to go on to
the orange team side that pageant coming
on but the little miscommunication there
and it's gonna create an opportunity for
Rob to get something going in the middle
here but no it's Chris Pereira the
smoking man x clearing it back out to
midfield work in that reverse game
feeling pretty confident if he's able to
put a corner together a little bit of a
center together with the reverse but
Rob's able to clear it out with those
aerials he loves so much
not a bad Center attempt by Matt Padgett
there J Waka 85 we've got robbed
handlery as Turco bango and playing
under the guise of Peter Brown it's
scott butterworth tracking across the
net now as who a nice little bicycle
kick by Chris Pereira to bunk punch it
back in try to get it oh the slow roller
is always killer and he's going to be
able to put n go passed Scott
Butterworth not able to track back fast
enough let's get a closer look at this
as he goes for the bicycle and then
straight backs up into it another
bicycle to open the scoring here with
about 40 seconds elapsed and we're back
to the next kickoff Chris Pereira going
backward more than forward it seems like
at this point match you know you got to
be comfortable with the reverse and
rocket League because sometimes that's
just the way your momentum is going and
momentum can be really key to getting
those strikes that you need to getting
those angles that you need you just have
to be able to use all the tools in your
repertoire yeah Chris seems like he's
got a pretty good all-around game he's
been playing some solid defense from
what we've seen not that they have been
on defense too much but of course Rob
handlery one of the when I think of Rob
handler I think of you know aerials and
more offensive so see if they can round
out their defense in this match to to
kind of tie it up and maybe pull ahead
all right that's gonna be Scott that's
his job to get in the way there and he
did it obstructed him a little bit now
it's gonna come back at in front not
really a play here as it comes high and
Matt Padgett Center laughs are it's
gonna bounce back into the midfield for
Chris Pereira to make a play on and will
he cut it back here he's working some
dribble action trying to get that flip
to happen but now it's rob with a big
clear he's gonna chase on to it if he's
smart he's got an angle that's a nice
shiny gadget backtracking not able to
make a play on it Rob answers for the
blue team with this nice little goal
here boom finishes it and it's one to
one both teams getting there cutting
their teeth on these early goals Rob
handlery pulling through really need to
make the make the play they're being the
I guess the pro in terms of the pro-am
tournament structure and iza seems to be
pulling some weight so far at least
they're tied up they're all tied up and
if we go we can in a little bit we'll be
able to go to a player view actually
right now obey Him there's a demo
vicious destruction by Chris Pereira as
Scott Butterworth trying to figure out
what to do with that ball not a bad move
at all and now this one's in front is
dangerous but Scott has got any that is
some strong defense from Scott
Butterworth that is going to be key in
blue team's hopes of coming out of this
match with a win now he's back he's
gonna try to sweep it why but he misses
badly and that's gonna go right in front
able to make a play on it oh just as he
was making some strong plays it's this
miss that really costs them it's got to
be kicking himself but that's a nice
finish by those guys rob not quite there
in time went wide around the corner
tried set it up but did not pull through
at the last second all right Rob playing
the defensive here and we're gonna look
at I'm statistic to the fly actually for
now I love you feeling about this view
Mike I like it maybe a little lower a
little in the action will sort of the
action yeah alright go get them awkward
bounce off Rob's roof and it's going to
come back in Chris prayer of that strong
Center game in mankind's gonna be able
to finish it no we can't get the angle
that was a great opportunity but Matt
not able to dig it out and now Rob
chasing it off that left wing but no
it's chris with a rebuttal Scott at the
midfield that's a nice challenge but
that pops it up and in that pageant
invented Matt Padgett to finish there we
go orange team shown been shown some
some strength in the last couple minutes
of this game yes Rob and Scott can
respond we saw a couple misses by Matt
early on but that one solidified into
the back of the net strong work by Jay
Walker here let's see how these teams
fair with two minutes left to go Rob
comes out for the challenge totally beat
but Matt is just a little high on his
flip Wow their hearts have got to be
beaten but there's another destruction
from the orange seem not afraid to get
their hands dirty I like to see that you
know the body game is definitely
important in rocket League and you know
Mike you play online and you see some
people apologizing or getting a little
cheeky when they get destroyed what's
your feeling on physical play in rocket
League oh if you're a physical player go
for it it could be part of the game if
you got that breakaway goal and you need
to box someone out I have no qualms
about doing that and people that know
how to do that well
just add another dimension to the game
that others might not be used to
absolutely a dangerous little set there
earlier from the orange team that the
blue got away with one and here's
another one Rob's gonna go up roll he's
gonna deny that says that was key
because Chris Pereira lurking there and
ready to make a play that's a nice job
getting it back out to the side but it's
coming back in the middle Rob with an
aerial intent and where's the ghost guy
coming in in just misses it a little bit
wide whoo and now the pressure is really
on blue team with a minute left they're
down to they need to make something
happen here if they're gonna have a
chance of sending sting into overtime we
go for those no and here's a good setup
Chris Aurora glee's up the corner let's
watch this happen here the smoking man
is smoking man up the wall flips down
onto it although hits it right in that
is one of the best goals we've seen in
the tournament so far almost a replica
of the goal that Chris waters himself
pulled off yesterday man that was one of
my best goal so Chris Pereira must be
feeling pretty stoked with that one and
I believe that'll be the nail in the
coffin for the blue team three goals in
45 seconds that's a tall order I don't
think they're going to be able to come
back from this another good set could
happen again especially the strong
offensive pressure from this orange team
okay now both of them tracking otherwise
the middle but they're both on top of
each other no one's back to stop that
but unfortunately for Pereira that goes
wide hits the post and bounces out
giving blue team a little bit of a
reprieve now maybe they can try to end
this one on a strong offensive note as
Rob pushes it forward Scott hanging back
playing defensively really not even
necessary at this point but I is there
gonna be there to collect this no he
backs off of it oh but he goes on to it
and then had a nice angle on it but
didn't quite make the shot pageant
pushing it up again into the corner but
letting it be as the countdown goes he
just heads home for a little safekeeping
in the net and that's gonna be the end
of the first match here in our evening
matchup in the game swap pro-am Chris
Pereira Matt Padgett taking the first
one over Rob handlery he's got
butterworth by a score of four to one so
I'm seeing a orange team much better at
covering more of the field they're not
really swarming the ball they're kind of
you know both of them transition
in between defense and offense more than
I saw blue I saw blue doing more the one
person on offense going for the goal
while the other stayed back I think if
Robin Scott want to kind of say
themselves for those just joining it's a
reminder that is best two games out of
three so blue team is still in I think
they need to kind of be a little more
aggressive I wasn't seeing it that match
that's true they're gonna have to
definitely generate some offense and
it's not gonna be all Rob you know
Scott's got to push up a little bit he
was doing all right at the midfield
there's got to make a little bit more
contact but I think you know for 21
there are a few goals there they could
have avoided I think that there's still
a chance for these guys to pull out a
good second match blue team still in it
for sure and now i'm gonna ready up and
send us into the second match here in
this best of three first-round game
between the well I'll let you know what
the teams are won the school board Gil
dug up here we go blue team Rob and
Scott here in the game spot office and
orange team Chris Pereira and that
Padgett each in their far-flung corners
of freelancer e here at gamespot now the
kick off momentarily
both teams leaving one back and that's
what I prove a ship i met Padgett as
Matt Padgett wins that one and has a
chance to put one by Rob but goes a
little wide and now this is a great
chance for Chris Pereira to put it in
but Scouts back there and he's tracking
the ball nicely doing some of that
reverse work but here it's chris in the
corner what he was so dangerous in the
first match good jock there by Scott
Butterworth to get Chris out of us
scoring opportunity here NER or Rob
misses the flip and then almost gets
itself into trouble coming back around
on it but we're gonna watch this come in
that's a nice little drill shot this is
that flip he almost comes back and hits
it back out but not quite that's gonna
be a opening goal for Rob handler in the
blue team that's exactly the note they
wanted to start on scoring early in the
first 30 seconds that's gonna give Blue
team confidence they hopefully need to
pull this one out Oh miss my skunk motor
worth no jump on that one but Chris
Pereira was betting on it so he didn't
play it and there's another bad miss
these [ __ ] butterworth at the save Oh
Scott's back to Regina big when he did
when he both would possibly miss on the
goal line he was there great d by Scott
Butterworth when it counted because both
orange teams or chomp team players were
chomping at the bit this is gonna be a
weird one it's gonna be awkward Rob
coming in have gotten himself into some
trouble Scott making a bid on it but he
just puts it back into the center for
the orange team to take up to midfield
there a little bit slow giving the blue
team time to get back on it a little bit
of our boredness and the corner but with
a strong clear he's got a boost but he's
jocked off of his line by Chris Pereira
good physical play from this orange team
and now he overruns it a little bit
because Luke's back around to try to get
another bead on it he's trying to play
it safe to not let them get into that
corner hello to the foliage and a little
bit of stairwell there the outside of
this Coliseum arena and Rob Oh getting
it right by Carrera and they're pushing
it in on Padgett got one more than
bewdley drops it right in on him nice
read way to get down on right where
that's going to land and they're coming
back around Scott Oh making a little
awkward plays not gonna tag of hand
that ball was halfway across the line
folks you saw it I saw it and I couldn't
believe my eyes when Rob rocketed in
maintaining the 10 lead hold it off the
line with some staunch defense in some
clutch saves but now perera's on one
he's got a line he's gonna pop it up in
front another dangerous ball Rob's not
able to go with a nice finish capitalize
that is what they needed to get back in
the game here it was looking like the
staunch defense was gonna do something
good but then ah Rob with that clutch
miss what do you call it when it's
clutch but the opposite of clutch choke
stank no I said chokes chokes way better
truth yeah well that Felix tank is like
you it's a nasty shot Oh put some stank
on that but that was a really nice job I
magic to bury it in the corner off this
awkward highball Scott doesn't really
know to do with it now tries to loop
back around but gives Matt or gets
Padgett the free shot and Padgett does
not miss that time putting the orange
team in the lead it's 221 with two
minutes and 50 seconds left to go oh
it's got a little bit indecision on the
face off but gets a good bounce off that
one you know sometimes if you're coming
second to the face off that's the way to
go you can get the rebound hit and now
Rob pops it in back pageant with a good
line on it though and he's gonna pop it
that's gonna loop right in front Scott
with a clear when he misses what's
robbing a place he needs to make a play
and he does pulls it out and now they're
both trying to get it out but they put
it in their front for Paul positioning
himself as a little door jamb there
right in front of us 20 counted kept him
alive for a little longer nice little
flip there by Scott that kind of
anticipation and this one's gonna be a
weird one he's got a balloon and he does
good solid defensive plays nothing
that's my goal keeping Rob making up for
that earlier gaffe with a nice stop now
Scott's onto it sending it down the
field Padgett probably back in goal he
definitely plays defensively as he told
us in the pregame interview and Rob can
you loop it around no he just creates a
really bad situation near Pereira but he
doesn't get the angle in so it's going
to be another center oh it does not look
good grad mrs. this is just an easy
one for him to mop up just too antsy to
get this one cleared I think you let
this one come down a little bit more
maybe you don't make that aerial miss I
don't know what do you think Mike yeah I
think that was just a matter of someone
over committing and then the other team
capitalizing on it and Rob says it best
himself whoops well as you know yen
getting the kickoff to go right towards
the goal forcing blue team to make an
early save this is a nice shot to the
far corner by Pereira but it's not going
to go in he's gonna come back and dig it
back out for pageants to take a shot
Padgett is there but Rob rebuttal Oh
destroyed by Pereira solid demo the
other demo that we see where you know
blue player in a good position to make
an offensive play and pereira just takes
him out Oh Scotty here we go this is it
buddy good good pressure I'm gonna be in
the middle Rob fighting to keep it on
that side of the field that's what they
need to do I think when I do it can't
make the play off the wall so he loops
back around they're both going to need
to punch this in there's one minute left
this is do-or-die time for the blue team
and they are cutting off those angles
forcing those shots wide but this is
orange team basically possessing the
ball right now and oh Rob with a great
aerial shot is gonna make it no it's
just wide just missed the sneeze gets
the boost that he comes back around oh
just a little bit wide come back around
on that shot and now it's back in the
blue team's own this is not what they
wanted but Rob with a nice save and he
still got some time never say over till
it's over Mike Oh in a solid demo by Rob
Scott's coming up for the shot Scott is
routine east of his own medicine serves
up the demolition up to Pereira and then
Scott Butterworth loops around takes a
great angle on this right over Padgett
and blue team is alive they need one
goal 25 seconds this is very doable
folks this is exciting Rob handler in
for a quick face Scott Butterworth still
hanging back on defense a little bit no
he's coming at it they're on wants it so
badly oh it's in two seconds left it's
in the end and orange team just needs to
knuckle down but here's a looping shot
it's weird it's bouncing in front no
one's made up
it's got good hair it's so close Rob
makes another play oh my goodness is why
can they get under it and get it back in
the middle for a last desperate bid oh
it's gonna fall oh and there's pageant
with a clear that's gonna seal the deal
a dramatic close finish to that match I
honestly wasn't expecting it to be that
close it wasn't looking that good for a
blue team but they pulled it out with a
great goal by Scott Butterworth in a
nice play shame it ended cos blue team
looked like they were pulling it
together but it's the orange team with a
first-round victory the slow roller by
Scott Butterworth almost got brought
them back from the dead but not quite
they still had 25 seconds orange team
playing some solid defense in the home
stretch there very true Mike very very
true all right congratulations to Chris
Pereira and Matt pageant pulling out a
first-round victory over Rob handlery
and Scott Butterworth who will take it
to the loser's bracket let's take a look
at what that's going to look like here
for a sec before we wrap it up mr.
McCarty aye it's super tiny text I can't
read that at all so now we have it's
going to be mad pageant and crisper
versus Andy Bauman and Justin hey Walt
here we have Rob handlery coming into
the booth actually right now so let's go
ahead back to the in the booth cam
dramatic finish their rob as your team
is almost able to equalize but uh how
are you feeling after that first round
loss I can tell you this much the the
last 30 seconds there my heart was
Scott actually came in incredibly clutch
with that shot again you know I having
set here in the castro booth they don't
I had it all figured out uh it's tough
it's tough to figure out the position
here again this is what's gonna happen
is you get these teams thanks for
surgery you know you have these teams
right like they're we're consistently
good on both sides that's true they were
doing that one drop down shot was
painful oh my goodness beauty yeah
whoops i could but i had a couple whiffs
arrow whiffs like i always do you know
we saw the whiffs those are tough for
you guys definitely gave up a few goals
in the first round but some clutch goal
line saves that second round it feel
like that gave you guys a little energy
i did like on that Scott butterworth
goal how you gave Pereira a taste of his
own medicine blowing him up because the
orange team would playing a little
physical out there yeah ill he took me
how many times ET see you took me out
twice yeah as I was a you know trying
you're approaching yeah a potential
scoring play and lujah rasu franklin
very aggressive well you know loser
bracket it is right Chris that's true I
out that that feel it's all in the game
baby sometimes you win sometimes you
lose folks thank you so much for joining
us here for a quick Friday night
broadcast of our gamespot rocket League
tournament look forward to more action
next week after the long weekend holiday
here in the States we've got to have
anymore first bracket situation 94 what
about Danny and on we have mad pageant
in the chat calling for that singing of
oh canada Matt it's just a first-round
win buddy but I'll tell you what you win
the championship I will sing oh canada
and i know all the work oh make it
promises i will i'll sing it for you
buddy right here on stream it'll be a
true patriots dream thanks for watching
everyone I'll talk to you later call me
yeah don't call he's a loser that was so
hard I'm a loser too we all can't all be
winners like this guy I am I'm in second
round I'm feeling good about it we play
Mary and Mike powers I I'll talk some
[ __ ] I wasn't impressed with their first
showing I think Marco and I are a solid
team I'm really happy with my partner
yeah on a good show yesterday he's
pretty defensive i will try to be
aggressive as far as the midfield game
goes keeping the ball on either side the
field so i don't know we'll see how it
works out marion powers solid team maybe
we'll even get some cameras out in the
audience so you folks can see the
madness as it unfolds as for now it's
time for us to pack this one in thanks
for tuning in folks will be back next
week with more rocket League hotness
have a great weekend